look let's give for the people that
don't know what's going on i'm going to
give you the breakdown elon musk has
offered to buy twitter to take it
private this is from the new york times
article elon musk offers to buy twitter
live updates his takeover bid at
54.20 cents a share comes just weeks
after he became the company's largest
shareholder here's what you need to know
um
twitter's stock price suggests that the
markets aren't convinced by musk's bid i
don't think i agree with that the new
york times is probably trying to spin it
so elon musk has launched a takeover bid
for twitter offering to buy it for 54
20 cents a share just weeks after he
became the social media company's
largest shareholder mr musk said that
this was his best and final offer
representing a 54 premium over the day
before he began investing in the company
in late january
uh in the filing mr musk said i don't
have confidence in management and that
he couldn't make the changes he wanted
in the public market so at that point i
mean
that's a pretty
damning uh a comment
from somebody who's kind of just just
arrived in the house hasn't even taken
their shoes off and he's sort of curled
a big fat one out in the middle of the
carpet in front of everybody
i don't like what you can make them for
dinner let me take over yeah
proper dinner this way otherwise i'm
leaving i didn't know because he's
actually posted the the tweet that's
gone super viral i bet that this is the
the
most accessed sec document
uh of all time
by far so he's just tweeted saying i
made an offer linking to an sec filing
which
presumably does that have to be made
public is that the sort of right okay so
this was out there in any case and
rather than him just letting somebody
find this he's decided to get out ahead
of it but it's got in it
it's got some exhibits and i don't know
how
common it is for this sort of stuff to
be shown there in it he says uh this is
him to brett taylor chairman of the
board i invested in twitter as i believe
in its potential to be the platform of
sp for free speech around the globe and
i believe free speech is a societal
imperative for a functioning democracy
however since making my investment i now
realize the company will neither thrive
nor serve this societal imperative in
its current form twitter needs to be
transformed as a private company as a
result i'm offering to buy 100 of
twitter for
54.20 per share in cash a 54 premium
uh my offer is my best and final and if
it is not accepted i would need to
reconsider my position as shareholder
twitter has extraordinary potential
i will unlock it so presumably you you
might be able to explain this better but
presumably what he's doing here is he's
saying um all of the shareholders in
twitter i'm going to offer you a 54
premium on i started at 38 premium on
the day before um
however if you don't do that
not only are you going to look like
you've been cooked to your own
shareholders but i'm going to withdraw
my i'm going to dump 10 percent of my
stock back into all of my ownership and
then the and then the stock will tank
down again
to wherever it was before the elon
mustang in the first place and so it is
and by the way you'll note that the 5420
number includes the the the number 420
which he also
did whenever he said he was going to
bring tesla private at 420 dollars like
maybe a couple of years ago back when it
was worth much less than that so he said
i've got a private buyer for tesla at
420 a share always this number 420 right
why is that and uh
why the number 420 is he's not memeing
his way through
are you sure because are you kidding are
you trying to suggest that elon musk is
using 420 like blaze up day
as i
all that here's what i'm suggesting
actually here's genuinely what i'm
suggesting i'm actually not sure that
he's not doing that but the reason
that i think that this is so interesting
is that
is that um so much of of what you do as
a founder as a ceo as all of these
things really in the public sphere so
much of what you do is about telling a
story and people believing in you and
honestly if i can be if i can be super
clear i again being back to being
earlier on every on everything
when i was i bought tesla stock really
really long time ago and and since it's
like the one thing i wish i had put like
all of my money into but didn't
but but what happens is you're looking
at a company that effectively was
insolvent and wasn't gonna succeed
unless he was able to get people to
believe
and i'll tell you what he's really good
at is getting people to believe in
something
and then that allows kind of like that
story to write out and become dominant
but he's good at that like over and over
and over again surely if he's about to
take this company private his ability to
make people believe from a value
creation perspective now becomes
irrelevant people don't need to believe
in twitter as a platform they already
need it the difference with him with
tesla is that he his ability to garner
belief actually then pays out dividends
in terms of the share price
yeah that's definitely true it's a
different story
the main thing that he's gonna i mean
let's assume this is even real right
versus like it being some giant colossal
joke and he's gonna be sued by the sec
again which he was when he did the 420
thing in the first place
uh
is then i i think that there's a huge
percentage of employees they're gonna be
like i'm i don't wanna wanna work for
this company anymore and so you could
see how it like could completely tank
the number of people that wanna work at
that company but it's true
that twitter has a gigantic amount of
uh uh
common square uh
comment uh
commons
value that is in fact not properly
unlocked like and i don't know why it's
like people you know you know what uh
mark zuckerberg used to call twitter way
back in the day when both companies were
private he called it a clown car that
drove into a gold mine
a company filled with schmucks that
nobody
like nobody knew what they were doing
barely keep it uh
going
and it drove into one of the most
valuable opportunities in the universe
that's hilarious so there's a bit at the
bottom
i don't know what this is it looks like
maybe a whatsapp message or something so
this is again this is in the sec filing
right sec.gov archives blah blah blah
blah blah
and this must be musk as i indicated
this weekend i believe that the company
should be private to go through the
changes that need to be made so
presumably he's teed this up at least
over the weekend um after the past
several days of thinking this over i've
decided i want to acquire the company
and take it private i'm going to make
you send you an offer letter tonight it
will be public in the morning are you
available to chat and then there's a
voice
script he says best and final
a
i am not playing the back and forth game
b
i have moved straight to the end c it's
a high share price and your shareholders
will love it d
if the deal doesn't work given that i
don't have confidence in management nor
do i believe that i can drive the
necessary change in the public market i
would need to reconsider my position as
shareholder this is not a threat it's
simply not a good investment without the
changes that need to be made and those
changes won't happen without taking the
company private finally my advisors and
my team are available after you've got
after you get the letter to answer any
questions there will be more detail in
our public filings after you receive the
letter and review the public filings
your team can call my family office with
any questions can you imagine for a
second that you are
whoever it is that's received this
particular letter at twitter
last night you know it's a quiet
easy wednesday in the middle of april
and out of nowhere like what's that
message from elon musk and a voice note
and you go
all right
hold on a second yeah i wonder what this
is oh elon musk
i i know it's date night baby i i gotta
i gotta look at this yeah yeah just wait
there uh oh elon musk's offering 43
billion dollars
to take
my company private i like i said i own
like not a lot of twitter shares like
not i don't know 10k worth or some
number you know and like
i just want to hold on to them just as a
relic i want to put them on my wall you
know there's like a i didn't i never got
a certificate i don't think you get
certificates anymore
i'm on my wall you're like wow i knew
that i knew knew about this when you
know okay so he said uh what happens
next in musk's twitter takeover offer
this is from the new york times uh elon
musk offered 43 billion dollars here is
what will or or could happen next the
board reviews the offer the board will
work with its advisors at goldman sachs
to review mr musk's offer they will have
to consider amongst other things whether
the deal fairly values the company and
whether mr musk has the financing to
cobble together a deal the board cannot
simply decide it does not like mr musk
as a suitor but they can come up with
reasons why they don't like the bid like
for example his ability to fund it said
stephen davidoff solomon a professor at
the school of laurel blah blah blah the
board announces its decision the board
will likely take up to a few days to
review the offer if it rejects the offer
it can go in one of several ways it can
put in a defense mechanism known as a
poison pill
yeah
what's that
uh okay so the details of the poison
pill
is i
well the concept of it is if you if you
consume the poison pill it will kill you
and so if i understand correctly
it is uh there are there's a huge amount
of these in twitter's bylaws maybe and
by the way you know i
i'm i'm not super familiar with it but
there's in twitter's bylaws there's a
ton of poison pill provisions that
effectively said if a happens if b
happens if c happens
i
this this uh this i guess software or
this this public good so to speak is
protected
and so it's possible
and i don't remember what the poison
pill provisions are but they exist in a
number of different companies um bylaws
and at twitter my understanding is
there's a huge amount of poison pill
provision there's more more than in most
tech companies because they're trying to
protect it it's wild that that's what
it's called a poison pill it says the
poison pill limits the ability of mr
musk and every other shareholder to buy
up twitter shares in the open market
once it does it could still decide to
sell itself but without the pressure of
mr musk blah blah blah there are reasons
twitter may opt to not do the poison
pill which again i can't believe that
that's even a term uh maybe wary of
potential criticism that poison pill is
deflecting the concerns of a highly
vocal member of its community likewise
mr musk who's reported stake incentive
blah blah blah the board potentially
looks for a white knight twitter has
been looking for a sale ever since it
went public says howard birkenbuilt who
leads the capital markets firm at blah
blah mr musk's latest activity most
likely heightened interest in twitter's
amenability to a deal some private
equity firms may be put off by twitter's
limited cash flow but a number of
technology companies may take a look
given heightened interest in the social
media giant's power and reach um looks
like
the stock price
hasn't it's it's bumped about 10 in the
pre-market and then pulled back a little
bit today it's 15 higher than when musk
first revealed it but is still
down from a 77 high february 2021 keep
in mind like like snapchat went public
sorry that my timeline's a little weird
but let's say six years ago or something
like that
and it has i i believe it's even like
less users but is more profitable and is
trading better and and by the way like
and i i i hate snapchat and i had i hate
evan spiegel and all the people that are
associated with snapchat just just on
principle but but it's somehow despite
the fact that it it went public five
years ago versus public twitter that
went the public much longer over a much
longer time frame
like twitter still cannot get its act
together i like i don't know if if you
personally believe that this is
i have i have always thought of this
company and by the way there's a lot of
people on twitter's board that are that
probably align with this elon musk
philosophy of the founder or someone
with a great deal of value a great deal
uh a vision can take it over and make it
better brett stevens who's the co-ceo of
salesforce i think that's his name
drew houston who's the founder of
dropbox i forget the founder of
doordash's name but another dude who's
on the board of twitter and so
along with others jack dorsey the
current ceo twitter so it's like a bunch
of people probably aligned in the
direction of like
okay but what's he gonna do
and there's another that say well maybe
this is good we've been looking to do
this so who knows i mean the 21st
century is weirder than we've ever
than any of us could possibly imagine i
think we could agree on that twitter's
board met on wednesday according to a
person familiar with the situation who
wasn't authorized to speak publicly
hours after elon musk offered to buy the
company mr musk turned down a seat on
the board over the weekend leaving board
members who had recently welcomed him
into their ranks to weigh a proposal in
which mr musk said he has no confidence
in the management of the company but
what i found out was that the reason he
turned down a seat on the board is
because he couldn't have put in a bid to
take over the company 100 percent if you
got
on the board so that was one of the
reasons that you know twitter a while
ago and then think about you know the
other game that may have been played
here when elon first purchased his nine
percent steak and then twitter goes
oh [ __ ] elon's probably got the wealth
that he might try to take us over why
don't we offer him a seat on the board
because if we offer him a seat on the
board he can't take us over so they're
playing the game because originally
everyone was like elon's whatever a
silent partner he's not contributing in
the way that everybody wanted him to
which really isn't no one gives a [ __ ]
about what he does financially with
twitter everyone's bothered about what
he does operationally culturally uh in
terms of the branding and its policies
and stuff like that and um
yeah man i i was talking to dan from
drinking bros about this literally a
couple of minutes ago i was like it's so
wild and kind of cool
that we have somebody on the planet who
has the resources and the
motivation to do the things that
everybody else daydreams about doing you
know everybody in tech
has an idea about what they would do to
fix twitter which is the platform of
tech in any case yeah i mean i
definitely agree with that yeah and we
also like like founders
are younger than ever with more power
than ever right like keep in mind that
that ascent is more and more rapid than
it ever has been the acceleration and so
for me the person who really exemplifies
this or the pair that exemplify this the
most is patrick and john collison who
run and founded stripe
in
that must be 10 years ago or something
and it's since become a 100 billion
dollar company and it's still private
and then they're like yeah we're going
to try and solve carbon capture
which is like another obviously really
meaningful problem for the earth
and and so you have these people that
still have their um still have a certain
amount of optimism and still have a
certain amount of
of like feeling like they can still
contribute and they can still do
something
30 years ago 40 years ago and before
that if it all it may be different to
you but like it felt like
all the people who had this power were
old and cynical and we're just trying to
do like
like hold on to their cash and and get
it to become more valuable and nothing
else well how old is elon musk age
literally 50 years old bro so i mean
elon's elon's not a young guy you know
he's like slap bang in the middle of
what you would expect from somebody
that's doing this sort of stuff the
difference is that he has quite a young
spirit with him you know he's got that
very sort of contrarian heterodox [ __ ]
you to the man dog point of the moon
thing and i dude i'm i'm in for this so
you know
moving beyond what's going on here
there's some stuff about salesforce
tried to purchase twitter and the sale
went through and some other bits you
know everybody can go and read the new
york times article if they want to go
and find out a little bit more about
this but um i think
actually first question is this what's
considered a hostile takeover
that's a great question i think the
answer is
uh
yes
what a hostile takeover is strictly like
legally speaking i'm not clear on
but the uh the understanding is that it
is a hostile takeover in the sense that
it is being done without the permission
of any anyone else that's that's
involved and it's effectively like
backing all the shareholders and the
board maybe into our corner
interesting so i'm looking at some of
the biggest replies
uh some of the highest replies here um
a man who's willing to spend 41 million
dollars for free speech is a good man
that i can admire someone replying said
if you're paying billions you're buying
speech it's not free i don't know i mean
what is it the thing that i don't get
is people's aversion to elon musk oh but
they have they have a very strong one
it's interesting because like people
often make those comparisons with jeff
bezos too and they're like oh like how
rich is he really and they show like an
ant and then a skyscraper and they're
like let's this is you and this is how
rich he is and they show these crazy
comparisons
of wealth accumulation that are
admittedly like out of proportion with
the past because of because of tech and
again that acceleration that was able to
happen it happens faster than ever
but then uh there's this automatic
assumption
that all they're trying to do is
accumulate like like money is no longer
valuable to these people and so then you
could think what's the next thing oh is
it power that seems simplistic to me
it really feels like they want to make
the world
you know maybe the language's neutral
languages like in their image and that
could be some good and some bad
but i don't know like
space travel feels pretty good to me
you know and electric cars feel pretty
good to me like admittedly
one of the stories of elon musk is he uh
he i think he made some money from his
previous company zip something before
paypal or whatever and immediately went
out and bought a one million dollar
mclaren car
and crashed it on his first ride out so
we're not talking about a normal person
but we're still talking about somebody
that has more vision than the average
twitter shareholder i would say more
vision but the thing that's interesting
is
all of the
uh
like new world order accusations that
get thrown at bill gates bill gates
doesn't have as much wealth as elon musk
but for some reason
more people seem to be happy with elon
at least from i guess like the center
right side of the fence certainly seem
to be a little bit more happy with him
because he's kind of cool and young and
hip and does like meme coin stuff but
i
i just don't know
i just don't know what it i don't know
what people's problem with elon is
overall i don't think he's
said anything particularly
egregious you know he i don't think he's
got like a secret alt-right past i might
be wrong right yeah yeah i'm not sure
that that's i don't think that's the
case either but there there is this
thing that happens and the general
attitude in tech right and it's true
everywhere mark andreessen elon musk
like jeff bezos was more neutral and by
the way people did feel this way about
bill gates in the 90s during the
antitrust
lawsuits that were going on with the
government but it's sort of receded
since then
and bill gates became this dude that is
almost like uh john rockefeller senior
john rockefeller senior his post oil
monopoly thing that he did
is he went out and he spent an in a
gigantic amount of money
uh donating donating it towards uh
mostly medical causes and his his father
was a quack doctor and so he was like oh
okay well medicine needs to be evolved
and all these other things essentially
what bill gates has done
and but these people are these people
are too young for that and and they
still have energy and they're they're
like i can run another company because
when you run one company i haven't run a
company as big as that but i have run
i've raised a lot of money and i've
built companies are meaningful size for
startups you're still like i think i
could do it again i think i think i
could make it better and easier this
time so i bet he still has a lot of that
energy in him there's a a bunch of
replies from gab are you familiar with
gab do you know what that is i am
familiar with the website gab yeah okay
so um there's one set of replies
counteroffer sell your nine percent
twitter stock invest two billion dollars
in gab join dab's board and let's take
them down you have to consider that
bringing free speech to twitter isn't as
simple as buying it apple and google do
not allow free speech so if you stop the
censorship blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah dude
this is the equivalent of the guys on
pornhub that comment
that comment things saying
oh
if she if i got my hands on her if only
i was in that room yeah dude she
wouldn't know what we got and you or all
the people that comment on the you know
glamour models instagram pages saying
looking so hot sweetie you go look dude
elon's not bothered about buying gab you
know
he's this is the thing is like is
anything off the table at this point
like that that's the part that really
scares the [ __ ] out of me homeboy's
playing in a 50 million 50 billion
dollar hostile takeover of the largest
town square platform on the world in the
world yeah for sure he you know gab as a
free speech alternative might be fun or
whatever but it just it just seems to me
like a really poor move i think
rumble did the same thing when
rogan got popped by
uh spotify about
is he gonna take episodes down and doing
apologies and things like that and
rumble were like oh we'll offer you 100
million bucks to go from spotify to us
and you think
i understand that when you're sat in a
boardroom that it kind of sounds cool
but when you're everybody else watching
on twitter you sound like the guy on
pawn hub saying that you should come to
you should come over to my casting couch
as opposed to the one that you're on
right now yeah and because the plat
those platforms like nothing's become
they're gonna become spotify like no
matter how much it like that's been won
and so that's the same thing with
twitter actually the common square it's
just twitter maybe maybe i don't wanna i
don't know about forever but keep in
mind like it is the one place where you
can go say some [ __ ] well maybe not
everything anymore i don't even know
about that but like you basically go say
some [ __ ] no matter how stupid or
offensive it may become
and it is public which by default on
snapchat because we talked about other
social channels before it is not on
facebook it is not
a medium that's behind paywalls now so
you not even there
i
on clubhouse i don't know that even is
relevant or i mean instagram's
instagram's got the equivalent amount of
access but you are you are right i
understand
i think that overall dude i'm so down
for this i'm down for everything just
but burn it all to the ground right and
let's start again let's go mad max total
scorched earth policy but it'll be it'll
be interesting to see what happens i'm
going to be interested to see how this
and if nothing else dude
the thing that i've taken away so far is
it's cool to have somebody that has the
resources and the motivation to actually
go after this sort of stuff it's i i
enjoy the fact that we live in a world
where
someone at least can offer this out you
know it's on twitter whether or not they
want to decide to take this thing
are there concerns about centralizing
control and ownership underneath one
person who you know let's say that elon
musk gets a a brain tumor in four years
time and decides to mean say that you
know make some ridiculous policies on
twitter and
completely destroy the platform you go
okay yeah maybe that's not good but you
also have centralized control currently
at the moment with someone who's going
through obvious dementia that's got the
nuclear football under his arm so you
know
the centralized control argument i'm not
convinced really really works but i'm
i'm glad it's happening i'm glad that
he's there what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace